when did you
first learn that billy joel was joining
the cast
for people that haven't seen the
episodes billy joel is a big part of
season two
he's trying to take over uh and lead the
boys after uh billy butcher uh
absence we actually replaced carl urban
you know with yeah it's kind of like
they do on the sofa
just just switched it with billy joel
yeah uh listen um i love the first
season i've loved what i've seen of
season two thus far
one of the things that is a constant in
every episode is a what the [ __ ] moment
something that completely comes out of
left field
what is it like for you guys reading
these scripts or is eric telling you
yeah you won't believe what's gonna
happen in episode three it's
funny because when eric pitches
uh us you know what's gonna happen in
the next couple episode
episodes he doesn't really
he always says we're not trying to go
bigger for bigger steak
you know um and then once we read the
episode we're like
eric this is huge like it's not even big
it's just huge
look at the whale how are you gonna do
that um and it's always so funny to see
all of the uh is it called mood boards
in the um conference room where
everyone's talking about like okay how
can we make this look
as realistic as possible and i think the
whale is even
anatomically correct i mean the heart is
pumping in the
um like literally pumping in um one of
the scenes
so yeah no i i forgot what the question
was but it's
it's great it's basically it's basically
going like
how are we going to do that and you're
reading it and you're going no
no no yes no really and then we get to
meet on set
and we do these crazy things and we
can't believe that
it's actually happening like
it's crazy yeah it is yeah and it's
fantastic to watch as an audience member
because i
am not being covered with blood in a
crazy amount of blood um what is it
actually like because
from what whatever i just had the
greatest idea
what if we what if
we uh created like a 4d space
where um everyone's watching the boys
in the audience and because it's 40 it's
like a ride but then like
instead of you know water rides it's
like blood right and this just gets
sprayed with blood
that'd be great sorry at the end of the
day i have a great idea
but i'm delirious you know what's funny
i'll bet you there's people who would
actually do something like that
i think the theme i love that idea i
would go for it
we should pitch it we should pitch it
yeah there's at least a few people from
amazon watching i was going to say just
cover the theater
in plastic and just be able to hose it
down
exactly exactly you know but actually
being serious for a second the thing
that
i've noticed in season two is that and
speaking to the other actors
that it wasn't like wearing blood for
like a few hours it was
you guys you know it was days and there
was just a lot to it
what is it sort of can you talk about
what it's like actually acting
covered like that or it must it must
affect you i can still remember the days
we were covered in blood
seeing the seven coming into set so
clean
and looking like they're coming from a
spa
and we were feeling like you know dirty
and sticky and then and and
it kind of we kind of looked at each
other and went like those
douche bags it just enhanced the whole
experience of
of filming uh uh this season
uh i think for all of us being covered
in blood
practically 14 15 hours a day
uh you know my mother calling me
saying send me some pictures
i you know it was it was it was uh
quite an experience but you get used to
it right karen i mean
you were trying to get used i would have
to say so i was looking through
um my photo library
last night because i wanted to kind of
spark some memories and
uh like refresh my brain about what we
went through and i've gotta say i
think all of my photos with you guys
have been
bloody there's practice there's
basically no
like not one photo where none of us have
blood on ourselves
so that's saying something it's not just
like a couple days either it's uh i
think it
almost felt like the entire season was
uh
covered in blood yeah i i sort of feel
like maybe you guys made your own evil
dead movie it's just called the boys
oh yeah you know um you know one of the
things that i found interesting was in
season two
you had a longer shooting schedule uh
like you had a few extra days on every
episode to shoot
um could you sort of talk about maybe
the added time you had and what that was
able to bring to season two versus
season one
we had added time
yeah er eric gave us some time to bring
the whale
to the ocean um well eric said
no i think i think i think i mean i mean
you know definitely
a bigger i felt it um
terms of uh sets and extras and and
and just you know i guess it's not just
us that are you know i'm having fun
the writers are just you know i mean
they're amazing and and i guess they had
uh
uh um more of a free hand you know to go
with
whatever uh they wanted obviously
because we get the most bizarre
unbelievably large-scale events
going in season two um
but in the end of the day for us as
actors and i think the magic
of the show the core of it
is uh the relationships and uh
the the the the fact that
besides um that's right a lot of blood a
lot of action scenes a lot of
whales and others
each and every character in this show
gets the most
round and fulfilled
world that they can uh as actors play
and that's uh that's you know combines
this uh
very uh conflicted
combined relationships that is in the
end
in the end for me this is like the most
interesting thing
as an audience if you don't care about
the characters it's um
you don't care about any you won't care
about the action yeah
you know i already have to wrap good
luck with the rest of the interviews and
your speed dating
thank you so much for your time thank
you